Wird es euch im Homeoffice auch manchmal
zu viel? E-Mails hier, Telefonate da.
Slack, Skype, Zoom, Whatsapp, Teams,
Telegram, Chat, Call? Waaaaaaaaaa!
Und dabei soll/will man immer präsent sein.
Also reagiert man sofort auf Nachrichten,
E-Mails, Telefonanrufe … Und zwischendurch
versucht man einfach weiterzuarbeiten –
irgendwie. (Du, ich kann grad nicht.
Äh, ich dreh grad’n Video.)
Wie aber kommen wir durch diesen
Kommunikations-Dschungel,
ohne durchzudrehen?
Ich hätte da ’n paar Tipps für euch!
Legt fest, was ihr wann machen wollt,
also wann ihr welche Aufgabe erledigt
und wie viel Zeit ihr dafür einplanen wollt.
So könnt ihr euch besser
auf eine Sache konzentrieren.
Unterbrechungen können
richtige Produktivitäts-Killer sein.
Untersuchungen haben ergeben, dass es
durchschnittlich bis zu 23 Minuten dauert,
bis man wieder in ein Thema findet,
nachdem man unterbrochen wurde.
Was mich gleich zu meinem
nächsten Punkt führt:
Setzt Prioritäten! Wenn ihr kontaktiert
werdet, überlegt euch: Muss ich jetzt sofort
antworten?
Oder hat das noch Zeit?
Wenn jemand unsere Hilfe braucht,
dann sollten wir diese leisten.
Allerdings unterbrechen wir dabei
unsere eigene Tätigkeit
und das könnte wiederum den Fortschritt
des gesamten Teams beeinträchtigen.
Wir sollten es also immer abwägen.
Natürlich gibt es auch
dringende Angelegenheiten,
die sofort geklärt werden müssen.
(Du, ich dreh grad ’n Video.
Aber ich ruf dich in einer Stunde zurück.)
Aber wenn nicht, verschiebt es und
konzentriert euch auf eure aktuelle Aufgabe.
Versucht, die Kommunikation
euren Bedürfnissen anzupassen.
Womit fühlt ihr euch wohler:
sprechen oder schreiben?
Ich weiß, natürlich kann man sich
das nicht immer aussuchen.
Kristina, heute ist mit Kamera! Kristina?
Ich habe einige faszinierende Aufsätze
darüber gelesen, wie viel schwieriger
diese Kommunikations-Tools
für Frauen sind als für Männer
– zum Beispiel wegen der Beleuchtung und
wie das Medium einen selbst wiedergibt.
Viele von uns kommunizieren
lieber in Textform.
Darum könnten wir verabreden,
Dinge über E-Mail oder Slack abzuklären.
Andere wiederum greifen
lieber zum Telefonhörer.
Und das nimmt sofort die Anspannung
vor einer Videobesprechung.
Noch eine Sache zu Mails:
Versucht, aus so vielen Verteilern
rauszukommen, wie es nur geht.
Wir verbringen täglich zwei bis drei
Stunden damit, unsere Mails zu checken.
Wäre doch toll, wenn wir
das reduzieren könnten.
Macht Pausen! Wie oft haben wir
das schon gehört … macht Pausen!
Aber ernsthaft: Macht Pausen!
Das ist wichtig für eure Gesundheit und eure
Produktivität
– genauso wie ein ungestörter Feierabend.